the big HR consulting companies they do
surveys every few years of employee
engagement and they've been doing this
for many decades and the results are
kind of depressingly consistent what
they find is that on average around the
world less than 20% of employees are
highly engaged in their work often in
some countries are in many countries the
number who are positively disengaged
isn't even a bigger number and then you
have the ones in the middle who kind of
show up collect the paycheck but really
aren't very excited by what they're
doing so you think about that around the
world the vast majority of employees
eighty ninety percent of employees are
there physically but they're not there
emotionally they're not there with their
full kind of creative spirit and this is
a price that we can no longer afford you
know in when we were back in kind of the
traditional economy where a success was
simply about diligence and focus and
discipline and so on it really didn't
matter that people were being treated
like and were kind of behaving like
automatons there was there is not much
of a price to be paid for that but in
the creative economy where wealth
creation is a product of new ideas
innovation this is a hugely expensive
waste of capability you know most of you
will you remember Maslow's hierarchy of
human needs with water food and so on at
the bottom self-actualization at the top
let me suggest there's another kind of
hierarchy that might be useful given our
conversation here and that's a hierarchy
of human capabilities at the bottom you
have obedience people who show up every
day they do is you ask them to do they
follow the rules ethical and otherwise a
level up from that you have people who
are diligent they work hard they stay
till the job is done and on top of that
people who have world-class skills well
trained and great intellect
now I would argue those are all
important human capabilities but
obedience and diligence and intellect
they are becoming global commodities I
can buy those capabilities for next to
nothing from Bangalore to Guangzhou all
around the world and if that's all
you're getting out of the people who
work in your organization you're really
not going to be able to compete in the
global economy not unless you want to
join the race to the bottom so we have
to go beyond obedience villages
and intellect and ask well what else
should we be getting how about
initiative people who see new
opportunities see problems they start
moving before anybody asks them they
they don't wait to be directed they're
out there moving before the boss even
knows about it folks who bring their
creativity to work or looking at other
industries are learning from other
venues and places challenging the rules
of the game in their industry and
finally people who bring their passion
work who look at their job as the way
they make a difference in the world
now those higher-order capabilities
initiative creativity passion those are
the things that create wealth in the
creative economy and yet those are also
the things that people are not by and
large bringing to work today initiative
creativity passion these are gifts
people literally choose whether they
bring them to work every day or not but
they can't be commanded not like
obedience or diligence can be commanded
so if in fact these are the capabilities
that create wealth in our economy if
these are the capabilities that that
hold the secret to getting your company
to outperform a very dismal economy
number one and number two if these
capabilities cannot be commanded but can
only be volunteered that really causes
us to turn our old management model
inside out tip it over 180 degrees you
know management is not today about
getting employees to fulfill the
organization's goals serving the
organization's kind of objectives today
management is about creating the work
environment a sense of purpose a sense
of excitement the right climate where
people are willing to bring those gifts
of creativity and passion and so on
they're willing to bring those to work
every day that is the new challenge of
Management and only if you meet that
challenge do you have a hope of
outperforming the economy
you